il villaggio è bellissimo e comunque
ogni volta che parte minecraft devo fare
un qualcosa di divertente cioè nel senso
non ho mai fatto la intro normale perché
no no no no no no hey hey hey hey hey
hey hey oggi ho preso quasi tutte le
volte sembra risolto polo di vedere le
deve essere fatto intestare la smetto
guarda ti ho preso esatto perché nel tuo
intimo ci sono le mie frecce ragazzi
siamo arrivati al villaggio quello
dell'altra volta che non abbiamo ancora
visitato ci sono dei cavalli esterna che
va dicendo tempo delle scelte ma ci sono
dei pony ma che cosa ci fai qua dentro
pietro o cosa ci fai qua lo cavalchiamo
lì come si fa una cronica ricordo e
dobbiamo avere delle stelle infatti
cavalcare non romperle va magagna ha
adesso abbiamo risolto il problema dei
cavalli in cavalcavia benissimo che
bello questo villaggio famiglia cosa c'è
dall'altra parte che gaga che paga
incredibile ne è uscito un village a
dalla porta ma mi spieghi perché i
cavalli sono morti è stato il village
ho visto io ma che tipo di cocaina ha
preso quel tizio certo che è una
discussione di gruppo che fa paura
questa mi unisco anch'io sto parlando di
bossi mi sento male dai basta e abbiamo
visto tutto nel villaggio tranne le
galline perfetto preso tutto quello che
potevamo prendere mia via non avremmo
avuto tanto ammazzare i villager però
oggi mi sento buono il sac è arrivato il
momento di esplorare il deserto visto
che siamo arrivati qua e abbiamo visto
abbiamo fatto solo tappa al villaggio
con dei cavalli con i cavalli facciamo
niente perché come vedi qua c'è una
scalinata grossa e cavalli mica sanno
attraversare l'acqua
e allora ho previsto il fatto che i
cavalli ci avrebbero rallentato gli
ammazzati tutti ai da mangiare
ma no non te lo do allora ce l'ho io non
voglio io
di qui lo strato di pani quanti ne hai
bandierai no io mi avvicino di prendere
maggio grazie ad esso fare la stessa
cosa con le banconote da 50 euro come
un deficiente scrivi girami su
un foglio da entrambe le parti la iena
ricordavi cave volanti sì certo
ricordata forse c'era anche un cavallo
però è sentiti ammazzati tutti cosa vuoi
noi stiamo andando ammazzarli esplorare
lo respiriamo capito ma bello sto posto
quanto è grosso sto deserto presenti ho
perso ecco li vedi pietro questa è la
quantità di ragazze che ti cercano cosa
vuoi adesso vecchio la spada di aida
ribadire ai di highbury diremo grazie
i cavalli non servono a niente servono
solo a morire perché i cavalli sono dei
pezzenti
noi andiamo alle gambe pietro campo di
attività fisica su chi lo stato non lo
sai ma i cavalli stanno bramando stare
il mondo per quello vanno eliminati ok
non lo sai per e cavalli sono brutte
persone a ma io pensavo fosse una specie
di collina ha fatta sabbia come quanto
figo aspetta che bellissima sta cosa qua
sarà figata incredibile aspetta che poi
guardato davanti
mettiti davanti alla porta così faccio
io ti faccio la foto tipo facebook ti la
mano e della regina a praga pyramid
famiglia bella foto ai mezzi di lì che
ti tago
se vai vai guardame alza la mano e
scattata perfetto sei venuto benissimo
sarai l'orgoglio della famiglia con
questa foto sul comodino posso entrare
occhio che secondo me piramide sinonimo
di trappole quindi qua
no no dài dài piramide sino al i voli
trappole quindi tanto mi sono murato
dentro sono scemo io ma che ci siamo
allora la prima cosa che facciamo e
spegnere i fuochi che sicuramente c'è
una cesta nascosta non c'è una vita
nascosta scherzava o e tutankhamon sono
gli zombie quindi occhio non so sono
creeper più zombie maledetti d'occhio
occhio a spacco io spacco io qua spacco
io perfetto squadre
fabio grosso sta pirati l'istruttoria
cielo fare ti metti toh sentito ai torce
sì quindi la piramide si prosegue in
basso quindi è fondamento pare sì va
bene vai spaccatutto spaccatutto race
hanno sparato
mamma mia quanto stanno sfogando e va
bene faccio fuori perfetto l'ultimo
evento buonissimo ce l'abbiamo fatto
fammi capire un attimo 9 ma che casino è
un labirinto loreo di amici giocare
lander man allora chiediamoci
dividiamoci nei film horror si dividono
sempre tutti poi muoiono tutti però non
è il nostro caso
qua non è della strada giusta te lo dico
io ahia ahia chi male rompe scuole
calcio è perfetto
niente nero di qua architettato troppa
no è stato molto figo che un labirinto
gigante cioè io non sono che permette le
torce così sappiamo da dove stiamo
passando dove cavolo sanzioni stiamo
andando non sanno capito amico ragni 26
dove sei più tanto perso anche io 26 non
ci perdiamo che con casinò finito le
torce cena i pini o ancora un po io non
trovo dei diamanti e paris hilton e alla
fine non è valsa la pena vabbè il fila
indiana gli zombie in fila indiana porto
una cesta 62 torce vai da un occhio
[Musica]
la mamma è pieno di bedrock intorno a
questa roba non ci siamo questa cassa
niente niente andiamo avanti
perfetto stiamo mandando all'aria sud
neanche tutankhamon aveva un grosso sto
posto ma basta certamente un ora che
stiamo andando avanti giusta piramide e
aspetto che consistono casi mi sa che
siamo arrivati ad una delle stanze porca
vacca cosa vedo mamma mia il prode i
prossimi scheletri li vediamo su una
mazda mamma mia
troppi troppi troppi fare sto morendo
sono fuori a sto mondo e cosa vuoi da me
e si è ucciso
se ho ucciso io mamma mia quanti sono
pietro micca pista che ci voglio anch'io
forte se vi sono talmente forti
no non lo regala il te lo giuro non ce
la faccio a scorgerlo muoio muoio e
scappa a a mi sono quasi protetto ok
sono protetto cioè non ai dadi che
casino ho fatto per proteggermi quando
ci mettiamo arrivare con tanto
mamma mia oh se sto avendo difficoltà
guarda che ho solo ridotto se sta avendo
difficoltà io con un eremo con un elmo
così con delle scarpe così e con la
spada così severa in questa parte
impossibile fi è bravo a uscire
quanta gente ai papà mamma mia che
disastro
no no no lancia una tiene di pietro no
continua la donna che casinò è
impossibile siamo un po li sta menando
non offra facciamo ci facciamo io con la
mia spalla ce la faccio e io no
mamma mia quanto poi sono forti mamma
mia che casino ma veramente non ho mai
giocato una roba così difficile
no ma è impossibile dobbiamo spaccare un
ora di poter sbarcare dispone tra
l'altro attaccare impossibile che riesca
neanche volendo a spaccare chi sono no
no no no devi spaccare gli stoner pietro
e gli spari in mano in volte ma non ce
la faccio la mamma mia che disastro ci
provo ci provo non ci riesco non ci
riesco io ho fatto ciò che ci ha fatto
fare quanto si sa non ha distrutto
niente picchiandosi vai vai lanciani
picone che piccolo re dammi un piccone
non ce lo siamo salvi ora ho capito
hai fatto un tunnel per arrivare da me
sei meravigliosa guarda qua che porterà
come ci arriviamo alla fine anno
possiamo neanche scavare perché c'è la
band rock utilizzato problema
madonna io sto vedendo l'inferno fatto
cioè a cubetti
c'è veramente incredibile mai visto un
disastro così lo quanto è difficile sta
parte diventa che porte charlie abbatta
telai ne vede di meno
vedo molti di meno ma continua a sputare
quindi ognuno sullo sfondo e oppure
niente ora è sì vabbè però non possiamo
dal cielo sponde a senza aver fatto
piazza pulita a me cioè veramente sono
troppo ora forse si veda proviamoci
geologo jolo con calma lo spaccato lo
spaccato potere va bene va bene va bene
va già bene così
una si ok perfetto mamma mia che ansia
una va già bene ho già un traguardo
quindi siamo perché ne mancheranno altre
due credo bye bye bye bye bye bye bye
bye distruggere
aiutami aiutami non manca pochissimo non
riesca a distruggerla ce l'ha fatta
ce l'ho fatta si no mi sono salvato per
niente una idea
sono morti tutti basta c'è ancora una
schiatta porca vacca
mamma mia che disabile come la sostanza
bella ora sì che la posso vedere ma mai
è successo è una roba del genere quanta
gente io sono a livello 40 è una roba
incredibile non ho mai paura quante
preci abbiamo addosso cosa c'era dentro
niente no no no grazie pietro molto
genere di un problema la rete di me
uscire uscire potrebbe essere un
problema perché non possiamo scavare che
cosa facciamo
questa è la stanza iniziale che chiusa
madonna no basta ma ti prego basta
vai picchia ma quanta gente basta o dai
basta non c'erano stati come ho detto
croce bedrock come facciamo riuscire da
quando lo spirito e non lo so e mandare
a completamente a caso va bene no ha
detto l'ad della prima basta basta il
labirinto a edizione quindi quindi lo
sento di colore di qua non ci siamo mai
stati qui maledizione non ci possiamo
perdere in e rituali quale dai me lo
sento e dico guardiamo sempre qua no no
dicono fatto i conti con 99 quel buio
no dico è chiuso da dove si esce
maledizione allora senti non posso
passare la vita a cercare l'uscita di un
maledetto labirinto come si esce da fa
spiega meloni come come
facciamo sfida chi esce prima vince va
bene
no dai scherzo non c'è più non ti senti
di pietro è uscito
ciao pietro nola pietro buona permanenza
come si può uscire dalle sabbie d'oro
ragazzi spero che vi sia piaciuto
io ma quanti scheletri ci sono fuori
voglio morire
ok ci sono va bene va senza cosa ti dico
basta queste isole cioè maledizione
andiamo via
prendi la barca maledizioni sta
proseguendo anche per forza andiamo via
ma che c'è il tramonto e nessuno ci
rompe le balle sto facendo attivo le
barche nel secondo vai grazie el'altro è
qui
ciao pietro figlia fascino giungla qua
potevamo farla qua subito la casa quanto
è figo
io proporrei una roba visto che qui è
pieno anche di legno c'è una casa
decente e poi andiamo ancora in
esplorazione ma che figata qua o
un'isola decente era ora senza piramidi
cose strane la facciamo qua sulla riva
del mare per fare solo arrivare il marmo
quanto è si sia subito intrapreso
la strada vero vabbè io vado in
situazione ti lascio quegli oggetti da
mettere nella bank serie lascia le cose
in bisogna mamma le mette a posto
vai con la rai tutta la roba te la
lascio lì e made in esplorazione e
scherzando non vogliono di roba questo
cosa me ne faccio il costo non voglio la
metti nella mag
o c'è una c'è una casa sull'albero
venuto qua e spara addosso
non so parlare vado io sai riferito no è
no aspetta aspetta aspetta da casa dei
village ger modificata dice che c'è un
village a tema e non sembra ci potessero
essere villaggi sugli alberi ciao
ragazzi tutto bene ma che cosa assurda
di salire accesso non c'è niente c'è
nulla ma che e bellissima sta a
casa è fatta benissimo mi piace un sacco
raggiungimi posso spiegare dove sono
sono ecco chi guarda guarda la finestra
ok anche lo so no anche rotta per per
chiamarti a genna venica è pronto avere
basta
lei visionate tutte le case e bisogna
qui no questo no
mi ricordo che siamo arrivati tra togli
a fuori dalle fitte basta sentire
fermiamoci facevano a casa diciamo dalla
lega allora andiamo dietro dove sei dove
sei tutti ho perso tutto qua ma non è
visto il fiume arrivo maledizione ho
visto la madre ma quanto figo questo
ok allora e aspetta questo lancio psico
che abbia mai visto
ma è mille volte più bello di quello
della piramide a aspetta se in mutande
ce l'ho io la tua armatura cosa fa cosa
vai lì a tivoli e la foto quella foto
bravura guarda in partita grazie che
sono tutti dalle canne da zucchero si
ben effetto 6
allora ci accampiamo qua facciamo un
mini accampamento e nel prossimo
episodio ce ne andiamo
1 perchè dobbiamo dormire piccini sempre
qual è il problema
l'accesso la mettiamo fuori così
chiunque ruba quello che vuole allora io
ti metto anche le tue robe quale poi
tipi tu quello che vuoi
perfetto liberi cioè quelle bei ragazzi
direi che possiamo concludere qua visto
che abbiamo trovato anche questo ci sono
un miliardo di dan giorni sto in sta ma
fa comunque io spero che vi sia piaciuto
come se solo 100 mi piace anche la guida
descrizione si siete non ci vediamo da
ragazzi
[Musica]